A suspension bridge has two
towers that rise 500 feet
above the road and are connected
by cables that hang
in the shape of a parabola that
can be represented by y
is equal to 1/8,960 times x
minus 2,100 squared plus 8,
where x and y are measured in
feet and x is the distance
from the left tower in the
direction of the right tower.
What is the distance between
the two towers?
Let's draw ourselves
a diagram.
If we draw the leftmost
tower-- I'm
going to do it in orange.
So we have the left
tower right here.
That tower is at x
is equal to 0.
We'll call that x is equal to 0,
or maybe just call that the
0 point right there.
Then x is just measuring the
distance from that leftmost
tower to the rightmost tower, so
the rightmost tower in the
direction of the right tower.
This right here, maybe
the right tower
is right over here.
They're both 500 feet high.
The right tower is right over
there, and we don't
know where it is.
That's we have to figure out.
We have to figure out the
distance between the two, but
we just need to know that x is
measuring this distance.
It's measuring the distance
from the left tower in the
direction of the right tower, so
it's just traditional, just
like our coordinate plane.
That is what x is measuring.
If you say x is equal to a
million feet, you're going to
get something way beyond
that second tower.
If you say x is one foot, you're
going to get something
in the direction of the second
tower from the left tower.
So that's x, and then y, we can
assume is the height of
the towers, or is just the
height in general that we're
dealing with.
This is the y-axis, so we're
just dealing in the first
quadrant of the coordinate
plane, and that is y.
They're telling us that this
parabola, the shape of the
parabola, can be represented--
or even better, they're saying
that the cable that connects
these two is in
the shape of a parabola.
Let me draw that parabola
right there.
They're the same height, so
the parabola will look
something like this.
What we can do to figure out,
or one possible technique--
let me draw a better
parabola there.
That's even worse.
That's about as good
as I can do.
One technique for finding the
distance between the two is if
we could figure out the
minimum point of this
parabola, which is also going
to be the vertex of that
parabola, that's going
to be halfway
between the two towers.
If we can figure out this
x-coordinate, we can say
that's going to be halfway
between the two towers and
then just multiply by two.
Let's see if we can figure out
this minimum point, because
the parabola is symmetric around
it, and these are both
at the same height.
Let's see if we can figure
out that minimum point.
Let me rewrite this equation: We
have y is equal to 1/8,960
times x minus 2,100
squared plus 8.
How do we find the minimum
point here?
This whole expression that's
squared, this whole expression
is always going to be positive,
or it's actually
always going to be
non-negative.
It could be equal to 0, and so
this whole thing is always
going to be greater than
or equal to 0.
This whole thing I'm squaring
off in orange is always going
to be greater than
or equal to 0.
So what is the lowest value
that y can take on?
The lowest valued that y can
take on will happen when this
expression is equal to 0, and
this expression equals 0 only
when x minus 2,100 squared
is equal to 0.
That's only going to be equal
to 0 when x minus 2,100 is
equal to 0, so x-- let me write
it this way-- equals 0,
and I'm just talking about
this orange part-- when x
minus 2,100 is equal to 0, or
if you add 2,100 to both
sides, or x is equal to 2,100.
When x is equal to 2,100, just
out of curiosity, what is y?
If x is 2,100, this thing is 0
times 0, and y is just going
to be equal to that 8 there.
So this coordinate right here
is the coordinate x is equal
to 2,100, y is equal to 8, and
it's going to be halfway
between our two towers.
If this is at 2,100, how
far is this tower away?
Well, it's going to
be twice 2,100.
It's going to be 4,200,
and everything we're
dealing with is feet.
It's going to be 4,200 feet away
from that first tower.
So the distance between the
two towers is 4,200 feet.